منذ أن كنت صغيراً ، كنت أرغب دائمًا في
خدمة هذه الأمة بغض النظر عن المجال
في كوريا ، لذا أخبرتني غدًا أنك
ستذهب إلى قطاع مختلف
، علمت أنه لا يوجد شيء مستحيل
إذا وضعت قلبك وجوهرك فيه
كان تركيزنا على  كان موقف الاستماع إلى
الشباب والتفاعل معهم
فكرة بسيطة جدًا من قبل الشباب الذين
قالوا إنك تعرف ما الذي يسمح لنا بالجلوس مع
صانعي القرار حول مواضيع مختلفة
وحل التحديات التي تواجهها كان في الأساس
كيف يمكننا جعله عملًا ليس
فقط  16 وزارة ولكن جميع القطاعين العام
والخاص للمشاركة
مع الشباب وتسخير
إمكاناتهم ما هي أكبر
التحديات التي يواجهها الشباب هنا
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، هل تعتقد أن لدينا أكثر من
108 مليون شاب في هذه
المنطقة وإذا لم يكن هناك  الارتباط بين
الحكومة والشباب أو إذا كانت الحكومة
لا تفهم الاحتياجات الحقيقية
ومخاوف الشباب فإن الفراغ
سوف يملأ نفسها بشيء آخر
وشيء نراه أحيانًا  لا
يتحمل أجدادنا وقد بنى أجدادنا
هذه الأمة من الصحراء
بالمثابرة من خلال العمل الجاد بالجهد من خلال
الوحدة والآن حان وقتنا نحن
الشباب لتنمية المهارات والمساهمة في ذلك ،
سيكون هناك أشخاص يشاهدون هذه
المقابلة يقولون ذلك  يبدو
مثالياً للغاية ولكن نوعًا من المثالية بشكل مفرط ،
ما هي الطريقة التي
سترد بها على ذلك في جميع أنحاء العالم يشعر الكثير
من الشباب أنهم لا
يعرفون حتى ما
هي الاستراتيجية الوطنية للشباب في بلدنا أو
ما يفترض بهم  مباشر
لمنتدى الشباب العربي الذي يحدث اليوم في
القمة الحكومية العالمية تم تنفيذه بالكامل من
قبل الشباب لدينا 98
شابًا إماراتيًا عملوا في كل شيء
من المحتوى إلى تصميمه - دعوة
150 شابًا عربيًا حول العالم
ينادونهم ليلًا ونهارًا  تأكد من
أن هذا المنتدى هو الأفضل وأنه ليس
موظفين يعملون في الحكومة ، إنما
الشباب هم الذين يريدون التطوع بوقتهم
لرد الجميل وأعتقد أن هذا ما
يقوله سموه  ProjectSyndicate ar عندما يقصد أنه يقصد
إذا كان يقصد مع كل خطوة نستثمرها في
إمكانات الشباب
لأنهم هم من سيصبحون
قادة المستقبل ، لكن التحديات التي
يواجهها الشباب العربي في جميع أنحاء هذه المنطقة
موثقة جيدًا أنهم يصنعون  عناوين الأخبار
على أساس منتظم هي ما تفعله
هنا شيء يمكن تكراره في
مكان آخر أو هل هذا محدد للغاية
كما تعتقد
- ما يحدث في الإمارات العربية المتحدة اليوم ، لا
أعتقد أنه يمكن تكراره في جميع
أنحاء الأرض التي نود أن نشاركها
العديد من المنصات
والمبادرات المختلفة التي تم إنشاؤها بواسطة
أفكار الشباب التي جاءت منهم ، وأعتقد
أنه نموذج يمكن لأي شخص في جميع أنحاء العالم
استخدامه ولا يتطلب الأمر سوى الإيمان بشبابك.